competir en la calidad de productos,
en los precios ofrecidos,
y en los servicios e innovación realizados.
Eso es la competencia por méritos.
En un mercado así, es posible tener éxito.
Y ese es mi trabajo, como Comisaria de Competencia,
el garantizar que las empresas que negocian en Europa
se atengan a esas reglas.
Pero demos un paso atrás.
¿Por qué necesitamos reglas de competencia?
¿Por qué no dejar que las empresas compitan?
¿Acaso no nos conviene,
que ellos compitan libremente,
si una mayor competencia genera mayor calidad
precios más bajos y una mayor innovación?
Ciertamente en la mayoría de los casos es así.
Sin embargo, el problema es, que a veces, para las empresas,
la competencia puede ser a veces inapropiada.
Y esto es así, porque competir significa que nunca se acaba la carrera
y que jamás se gana el juego.
Sin importar lo bien que uno lo haya hecho antes,
siempre hay alguien más
que quiere reemplazar a otro.
Por tanto, la tentación de evitar la competencia, es poderosa.
Su origen proviene de razones tan antiguas como las de Adán y Eva:
En la codicia por más dinero,
en el miedo de perder un puesto en el mercado
y todo los beneficios que trae consigo.
Y cuando a la codicia y al temor se enlaza con el poder,
se obtiene una mezcla peligrosa.
Vemos eso en la vida política.
En ciertas partes del mundo,
la mezcla de codicia y temor significa que,
quienes obtienen el poder,
no están dispuestos a devolverlo.
Una de las muchas cosas que me gusta y admiro de nuestro régimen democrático
son las normas que llevan a nuestros lideres a renunciar al poder
cuando los votantes se lo piden.
Las reglas de competencia pueden hacer algo similar en el mercado:
evitar que la codicia y el temor triunfen sobre las reglas de legitimidad.
Porque estas reglas sirven para que
las empresas no abusen de su poder para eliminar la competencia
Piensen por un momento en su auto.
Cuenta con miles de partes que lo conforman:
desde cojines de los asientos
hasta el cableado eléctrico y focos.
Para muchas de estas partes,
las industrias automotrices
dependen solo de un pequeño número de proveedores.
Así que, no es de extrañar
que esto tiente a algunos proveedores
a reunirse y modificar los precios.
Imaginen cómo eso podría afectar el precio final
de su auto nuevo en el mercado.
Salvo que esto no es algo imaginario.
La Comisión Europea
ha tratado ya con siete diferentes consorcios de proveedores de automoción,
y todavía estamos investigando algunos.
Aquí es donde el Departamento de Justicia
evalúa el mercado de proveedores de automoción,
considerándola una de las investigaciones criminales más importante
que jamás haya hecho.
Sin embargo, sin reglas de competencia,
no se habría hecho ninguna investigación,
y no habría nada que detuviera esta conspiración
ni que el precio de su auto incrementara.
No obstante, no solo las empresas pueden socavar la competencia justa,
sino también los gobiernos.
Y los gobiernos lo hacen cuando distribuyen los subsidios
a unos pocos de sus escogidos.
Lo pueden hacer cuando distribuyen los subsidios,
obviamente, todos financiados por los contribuyentes,
a las empresas,
bajo la forma de tratamientos fiscales especiales,
como beneficios fiscales
que empresas como Fiat Starbucks y Apple reciben
de algunos gobiernos en Europa.
Dichos subsidios hacen que las empresas dejen de competir igualitariamente.
Esto puede significar que las empresas que triunfan
son porque reciben los mayores subsidios,
las que cuentan con los mejores contactos,
y no, como debería ser,
las empresas que atiendan mejor al cliente.
Por tanto, hay veces en que debemos intervenir
para asegurarnos de que la competencia funcione como debería.
Al hacerlo, contribuimos a que el mercado opere de manera equitativa,
pues la competencia brinda a los clientes el poder de demandar un trato justo.
Esto es para que las empresas sepan que si no pueden ofrecer buenos precios
o cumplir con el servicio esperado,
el cliente se irá a otro lado.
Y ese tipo de legitimidad es más importante de lo que a veces imaginamos.
Poca gente se detiene a reflexionar sobre la política.
Algunos incluso lo evitan en el periodo de elecciones.
No obstante, todos estamos en el mercado.
Cada día estamos dentro de él.
Y no queremos que los negocios acuerden precios en la oficina administrativa.
No queremos que se dividan el mercado entre ellos.
No queremos una empresa grande
que evite a sus competidores
mostrarnos lo que pueden hacer.
Si eso pasara,
claramente nos sentiríamos engañados por alguien,
ignorados u olvidados por el mercado.
Esto puede socavar no sólo nuestra confianza en el mercado,
sino también nuestra confianza en la sociedad.
En un estudio reciente,
más de dos tercios de los europeos
comentaron haber resentido los efectos de la falta de competencia:
que el precio de la electricidad era muy alto,
que el precio de las medicinas que necesitaban era costoso,
que no tenían una opción real
si querían viajar en avión o autobús,
o si su servicio de Internet era pobre.
En resumen, se dieron cuenta de que el mercado no los trataba de modo justo.
Desde luego, esto puede parecer muy insignificante,
sin embargo, puede hacerles pensar
que el mundo no es realmente justo.
Y ven al mercado, el cual atiende supuestamente a todos,
más asemejado a la propiedad privada de ciertas empresas poderosas.
El mercado no es la sociedad.
Nuestras sociedades son, ciertamente, mucho más que el mercado.
No obstante, la desconfianza en el mercado
puede contagiar a la sociedad
y en consecuencia perder la confianza en nuestra sociedad.
Y puede ser que sea lo más importante que tenemos... la confianza.
Confiamos en otros cuando se nos trata por igual.
Si esperamos tener todos las mismas oportunidades,
debemos seguir las mismas reglas básicas.
Es cierto que algunas personas o empresas son más exitosas que otras,
sin embargo, desconfiamos de la sociedad
si los precios se establecen
antes de iniciar la competencia.
Y aquí es donde las reglas de competencia entran,
puesto que cuando nos aseguramos que los mercados operen de manera leal,
entonces la empresa compite por sus méritos,
y eso contribuye a construir la confianza que necesitamos como ciudadanos
para sentirnos cómodos y al mando
y la confianza que permite a nuestra sociedad funcionar.
Porque sin confianza, todo se vuelve más difícil.
Simplemente para vivir el día a día, necesitamos confiar en extraños,
confiar en los bancos que cuidan de nuestro dinero,
en los constructores de casas,
el electricista que viene a reparar el sistema eléctrico,
el médico que nos trata cuando estamos enfermos,
sin mencionar a los conductores en las carreteras,
y todos sabemos que están locos.
Y aún así, tenemos que confiar
en que hacen lo correcto.
El punto es que cuánto más crezcan nuestras sociedades,
la confianza se vuelve más importante,
y lo más difícil es construirla,
la cual es una paradoja de las sociedades modernas.
Y esto es sobretodo cierto
cuando la tecnología cambia nuestra manera de interactuar.
Claro, en cierto grado, puede ayudarnos
a fomentar la confianza entre nosotros,
con sistemas de clasificación y otros sistemas
que posibilitan la economía colaborativa.
No obstante, la tecnología crea también nuevos desafíos
cuando nos pide no sólo confiar en otras personas
sino también en los algoritmos y computadoras.
Evidentemente, todos vemos, compartimos y apreciamos
todo los beneficios que la nueva tecnología puede ofrecernos.
Son muchos.
Los vehículos autoconducidos pueden dar independencia a personas con discapacidad,
nos ahorran tiempo a todos,
y utilizan mucho mejor los recursos.
Los algoritmos que se basan en el análisis de una gran cantidad de datos
permite a los médicos darnos un mejor tratamiento,
y muchas otras cosas más.
Sin embargo, nadie transmitirá información de su salud
ni subirá a un auto cuyo conductor sea un algoritmo
sin confiar en las empresas con las que tratan.
Esta confianza no siempre existe.
Hoy en día, por ejemplo, menos de una cuarta parte de los europeos
confían en las empresas virtuales que protegen sus datos personales.
Pero, ¿qué pasaría, si la gente supiera
que ellos podrían confiar en las empresas tecnológicas
en que se les diera un trato justo?
¿Qué pasaría si supieran que esas empresas responden a la competencia
intentando ser mejores, y atendiendo mejor a los clientes
y no por utilizando su poder
para derrocar a la competencia?
Es decir, poniendo sus servicios
en el último lugar, lejos de los resultados de búsqueda
y promocionándose ellos en primer lugar?
¿Qué pasaría si supieran que el cumplimiento de las reglas
se incorporó a los algoritmos en su diseño,
que estos superaron las reglas de competencia
antes de obtener el permiso de operar,
que se diseñaron algoritmos
de manera que no se pudieran eludir,
ni formar su pequeño consorcio
en la caja negra en que operan?
Junto con la regulación,
las normas de competencia logran lo mismo.
Nos ayudan a cerciorarnos
de que las nuevas tecnologías traten a las personas de manera justa
y que todos compitan en igualdad de condiciones,
ayudándonos a crear la confianza necesaria
para que las auténticas innovaciones prosperen
y para que las sociedades se desarrollen para los ciudadanos.
Porque la confianza no puede imponerse,
debe ganarse.
Desde los primeros días de la Unión Europea,
hace 60 años,
las reglas de competencia han ayudado
a la construcción de dicha confianza.
Ahora, muchas cosas son distintas.
Es complicado hablar de las cosas que esos seis representantes
habrían hecho con un smartphone.
Sin embargo, en el mundo actual,
así como en el de ellos,
la competencia hace que el mercado funcione para todos.
Y por esta razón, estoy convencida
de que la competencia leal y real
juega un papel muy importante
en la creación de la confianza que necesitamos
para sacar lo mejor de nuestras sociedades,
comenzando por la aplicación de reglas
que hacen que el mercado sea para todos.
¡Gracias!
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Gracias.
Gracias, Comisaria.
Margrethe Vestager: Fue un placer.
B.G: Quiero hacerle dos preguntas.
La primera es sobre los datos, pues para mí
la tecnología y los datos cambian la forma cómo evoluciona la competencia
y cómo se desarrollan y aplican las reglas de competencia.
¿Puede hablarnos un poco de eso?
M.V: Claro, definitivamente es un desafío para nosotros,
ya que no solo debemos mejorar nuestros métodos
sino también desarrollar nuevos.
Al revisar las respuestas de Google
a nuestra declaración de oposición,
revisamos en total 5.2 TB de datos.
Es mucho.
Así que, tuvimos que instalar nuevos sistemas.
Debimos comprender cómo hacerlo,
pues no podemos trabajar de la forma en que hacíamos años atrás.
Así indudablemente, mejoramos nuestros métodos de trabajo.
Además, intentamos diferenciar
los distintos tipos de datos,
algunos son extremadamente valiosos,
creando así una especie de barrera para ingresar al mercado.
Otros, simplemente... no valdrán nada mañana.
Por eso, nos cercioramos
de que jamás se subestime el hecho
de que en el mercado los datos funcionan como moneda y un activo,
los cuales pueden representar una verdadera barrera para la competencia.
BG: Hace algunos meses, Uds. sancionaron a Google por 2.8 mil millones de euros.
MV: No, fue en dólares. Hoy en día, no es tanto.
BG: Bueno, depende de...
(Risas)
Google apeló el caso. Se irá a los tribunales.
Durará bastante.
El año pasado, pidieron a Apple pagar 13 mil millones en impuestos atrasados,
además, han investigado a otras empresas,
incluyendo empresas europeas y rusas,
y no sólo estadounidenses.
No obstante, las investigaciones con relación a las empresas estadounidenses
son las que más han llamado la atención
y que han atraído algunas acusaciones.
Principalmente, se le ha acusado de proteccionismo, de celos
o de usar la ley para atacar a las empresas estadounidenses
que han conquistado los mercados europeos.
Esta semana, en la portada de la revista "The Economist" se lee:
"Vestager vs The Valley"
¿Cómo reacciona a eso?
MV: Primero que nada, lo tomo muy en serio.
La parcialidad no tiene cabida en la aplicación de normas.
Necesitamos respaldar nuestros casos con pruebas, hechos
y jurisprudencia para llevarlas ante los tribunales también.
Número dos: Europa está abierta para hacer negocios,
pero no para la evasión fiscal.
(Aplausos)
El punto es que estamos cambiando
y por ejemplo, cuando pregunte a mis hijas,
ellas también usan Google,
¿Por qué hacen eso?
Ellas dicen: "Porque funciona. Es un buen producto."
Ellas jamás me responderán:
"Es porque es un producto EE.UU."
Simplemente es porque funciona.
Y así es como debería ser.
Pero aun así, es importante que alguien diga:
"Los felicitamos
mientras vaya creciendo.
No obstante, dejaremos de hacerlo
si vemos que Uds. están abusando de su puesto
para perjudicar a los competidores a fin de que no puedan atender clientes."
BG: Será algo fascinante de seguir.
Gracias por venir a TED
Fue un placer. Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)